[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal a préparé par
les équipes de tv 78 nous sommes le
lundi 24 janvier voici les titres de
cette édition
le comité départemental de soutien à
valérie pécresse est lancée et élus
locaux se sont rassemblés ce week-end
derrière la candidate de droite
l'occasion d'en apprendre plus quant à
la stratégie de campagne adopter pour la
présidentielle
la boxe féminine se démocratise tél à
l'occasion de la journée internationale
du sport féminin
la boxeuse mariam bas tout sera avec
nous pour parler des préjugés dans le
sport nous vous indiquons également les
sportives à suivre dans les yvelines en
2022 le châtaignier de la celle saint
cloud est à l'honneur l'arbre a remporté
le prix du public du concours de l'arbre
de l'année âgée de trois cent trente ans
il mesure 12 mètres de haut un spécimen
à découvrir dans ce journal
[Musique]
l'est républicain des yvelines avec
leurs alliés de l'union des démocrates
indépendants yvelinois ont lancé ce
samedi 22 janvier au théâtre de la
nacelle à aubergenville un comité
départemental de soutien à valérie
pécresse
l'occasion de s'intéresser à la
stratégie de campagne de la candidate à
la présidentielle dans un département
quasi conquis un reportage de nicolas
d'andré et mélanie poké regard des
conseillers départementaux régionaux ou
encore municipaux de nombreux élus de la
droite et du centre étaient rassemblés
ce samedi 22 janvier une soirée pour
lancer le comité de soutien de valérie
pécresse dans les yvelines pour la
présidentielle 2022 des élus locaux
essentiel dans la stratégie de campagne
de la candidate
ça va être à eux aussi d'aller à la
rencontre des citoyens c'est donc
d'abord
campagne de rencontres
campagne des changes campayo où on
montre on écoute les français on essaie
de répondre à leurs problèmes et francis
ont besoin d'être entendus parmi les
acteurs de la campagne nicole pompidou
la belle fille de georges pompidou
deuxième président de la vème république
elle a en charge les relations avec la
société civile dans le département pour
soutenir valérie pécresse c'est une
femme quoi je m'attends tu intègres
et c'est une femme comme je le disais de
coeur elle aime la france et elle aime
les français c'est la filiation c'est
gaulle pompidou chirac et
et valérie présent aussi l'union des
démocrates indépendants des yvelines des
centristes qui soutiennent la candidate
et l'air en prenant leur distance avec
emmanuel macron et la république en
marche ce qui nous vraiment nous
séparent de de l'amac redit j'allais
dire c'est cet
exercice du pouvoir vertical et là c'est
quelque chose d'absolument
rédhibitoire lui d un allié historique
de la droite yvelinoise aujourd'hui ils
sont présents dans plusieurs majorités
deux élus régionaux quatre élus
départementaux et de nombreux élus
municipaux
et ce samedi 22 janvier avait lu
également la deuxième édition du salon
de l'étudiant en ville et s'est tenue au
vélodrome donc national de saint quentin
en yvelines après l'ouverture de la
plateforme parcours sup le 20 janvier
dernier les élèves de la seconde jusqu
aux étudiants en bac + 5 ont pu répondre
à leurs interrogations
au programme rencontres avec des
professionnels de l'orientation et
échanges avec une quarantaine
d'exposants étudiants représentants
d'écoles des conférences sur les études
supérieures étaient également donner
toute la journée des propos recueillis
par mélanie poké avec céline charles ce
salon est élaboré de façon à trouver
l'ensemble des possibilités qu'offre
l'enseignement supérieur donc à la fois
les formations publiques donc comme les
universités les lycées publics certains
cfa mais également les écoles
spécialisées privé donc dans le commerce
les écoles d'ingénieurs et pas de
communication idée le salon c'est
vraiment avant tout de représenter
l'offre locale de formation
dans saint quentin en yvelines et son
département
[Musique]
et ce lundi c'est la journée
internationale du sport féminin et tv 78
vous propose un diaporama est des
sportives les yvelinoises à suivre en
cette année 2011 22 coups de projecteurs
de michael et demi d'euros
[Musique]
donc
et je vous lise et juste avant le
reportage ce lundi 24 janvier c'est donc
la journée internationale international
du sport féminin et on aborde cette
thématique avec vous marianne batou
bonsoir
vous êtes donc boxeuse et vous faites
partie notamment de la team farrugia
d'elancourt donc les sports comme
football handball rugby la boxe donc
sont dans beaucoup d'esprits des sports
dits masculins quel regard vous portez
vous sur votre discipline déjà et
comment ça s'est passé justement pour
vous au début
bah moi j'ai commencé il ya quatre ans
dans le club où j'ai été ça s'est très
bien passé on nous accueillir rapidement
nous bien on nous met à l'aise mais
c'est vrai que
quand on voit une fille féminine qui
skie le se mettre à la boxe et tous on
ne prend pas au sérieux quand on prend
pas au sérieux du coup on est juste bon
on est là pour faire du loisir alors que
le pas du tout là je vais commencer la
compet moi j'ai commencé la compétition
et et bah du coup on est là pour casser
les clichés quoi on peut être féminine
et et faire de la boxe du foot j'aurais
dit peu importe et ouais franchement moi
je suis là pour casser les clichés
clermont je veux plus entendre ça en
on le souhaite on souhaite
est-ce que vous avez l'impression quand
même que la boxe en tout cas votre votre
discipline se démocratise un petit peu
oui de plus en plus haut la boxe
féminine on entend que de plus en plus
par les bat on voit même les clubs de
fitness qui ou des des sessions boxe moi
je vois je vois du shoot en milieu de
ses proches et c'est vrai qu'il ya de
plus en plus de licenciés
femme à la boxe et ça c'est super et
vous qu'est ce qui vous a donné
personnellement envie de vous lancer
dans cette pratique des sports de la
boxe moi c'était par par par hasard j'ai
fait plusieurs soirs avant donc j'ai
fait plein de sports collectifs 10 sport
individuel la gym plein plein de fois et
j'ai essayé la boxe vraiment par hasard
et j'ai eu un coup de coeur donc après
je suis resté ça fait quatre ans que
l'on fait
aujourd'hui donc on en est ou parce que
du coup il ya dsk selon vous il ya des
inégalités qui persistent donc dans le
sport en général est-ce que pratiquer un
sport donc comme on le disait 10
masculin s'est encore compliquée
aujourd'hui vous désirez y avait des
clichés comment ça se passe
bah on sait très bien par exemple que
dans la boxe en tout cas que j'ai
entendu les femmes ne gagnent pas
apparaît que les hommes dans la boxe
professionnelle
mais bon ça je sais que c'est vrai c'est
partout même dans le foot même partout
mais ça je pense qu'il faut remédier à
ça il me semble qu'il ya que le tennis
où les femmes gagnent pareil que les
hommes mais ouais c'est dommage c'est
dommage parce que pas parce qu'on
s'entraîne autant que les hommes donc je
vois pas pourquoi on serait pas
récompensés
à hauteur d'un même auteur et justement
donc on parle souvent de manque de
visibilité dans les médias ou encore de
manque de postes clés tenus par les
femmes dans le domaine comment vous vous
l'expliquer ces inégalités justement
dont vous parliez
j'ai pas entendu excusez moi comment
vous expliquer ces inégalités certains
disent que c'est parce que on est moins
médiatisé justement faire les
compétitions féminines sont moins
médiatisés d'autres disent que c'est
parce que les femmes ont moins de postes
clés dans le domaine dans le sport en
tout cas vous comment vous expliquer ces
inégalités moi je pense qu on n est pas
mise en avant en fait on est on est
moins mise en avant dans les médias en
du monde et en avant dans les
compétitions quand y ait des
compétitions de boxe par exemple y aura
plus de combats masculins que féminins
c'est possible de remédier à ça mais
faut
il faut que tout le monde y met du sien
il faut que ça va être des deux sens
nous ont fait un maximum
mais maintenant c'est aux médias de de
mettre en avant les sports les sports
féminins donc c'est quand même quelque
chose que vous ressentez un vous en tant
que boxeur dans le sport vous tolère
membres uc faire puis même on entend
encore des phrases du style mais qu'est
ce que tu fais dans un sport comme la
boxe ça ne va pas tu devrais faire autre
chose c'est pas féminin etc et à ses
rôles ou c c'est fatiguant on veut plus
entendre sorte 2022 et justement vous
dites voulait plus entendre ça en 2022
quand vous entendez des phrases comme
celle que vous vous prononcez qu'est ce
que vous répondez
au bon je dirais un mois je prouve sur
le ring en fait on est là on s'entraîne
dur autant que les hommes parfois plus
donc ils peuvent ils peuvent parler
après verront sur le ring et au final on
est là on a notre place sur le ring on a
notre place dans ce sport vous êtes là
pour le prouver en tout cas vous vous
avez aussi donc un compte instagram
actif puisque vous avez près de
cinquante mille abonnés en quoi ça vous
tient à coeur finalement de promouvoir
la boxe que vous le faites auprès des
femmes
moi ça me tient à coeur quand je vois
que
bah en fait je reçois énormément de
messages de personnes qui me disent que
l on sait pas si m que justement elle
avait peur de ces clichés ou peut-être
qu'elle se sentait pas à l'aise dans ce
sport là et le fait de que je poste
régulièrement et que je prouve qu'en
fait on peut on peut être une femme et
être épanoui dans des sports masculins
entre guillemets il y en a de plus en
plus ce qu'ils me dire où je me suis
inscrit à la boxe grâce à toi je me suis
lancé j'ai pris confiance grâce à sa
grâce à la boxe donc moi ça me tient
vraiment à coeur surtout que je suis
coach mortier donc j'accompagne des
femmes au quotidien et d'avoir des
retours comme ça et c'est incroyable
c'est déjà une victoire
c'est un peu c'est un peu une fierté
donc vous votre objectif c'est passer
pro c'est plus difficile aussi pour les
femmes justement où est-ce qu'on est sur
un pied d'égalité à ce niveau là pour
passer professionnel pour passer
professionnel sk plus de profession je
pense pas que ce soit plus difficile
c'est juste la l'inégalité aller au
niveau de jeu pense de la rémunération
mais sinon pour passer pro n'en sait pas
plus difficile qu'un homme donc on est
plutôt sur un pied d'égalité ce jeu les
clichés et au niveau du salaire en fait
c'est ça que vous nous expliquez moi je
pense oui
vous vous avez récemment remporter votre
premier combat amateur en boxe anglaise
si je ne dis pas de bêtises
félicitations qu'est ce qui vous attend
prochainement pour parler plus
précisément de vous et qu'est ce qui est
prévu cette année de votre côté bah moi
je mende est-il de plus en plus donc
prendre au moins ça à coeur oui je
prends vraiment ça au sérieux donc je
m'entraîne très dur très dur et j'espère
va faire d'autres combats de avoir
d'autres victoires et pour l'instant
faire une bonne carrière amateur et
ensuite passer pro et vous avez d'autres
combats de prévu peut-être déjà cette
année où pour l'instant on attend un
petit peu concentré non je pense que mon
entraîneur m'a parlé de d'autres combats
là il y avait la finale mais ça a été
reporté petit problème qu'a eu lieu la
compétition donc non non il ya d'autres
combats qui l'ont venir est ce que vous
pourriez avoir par exemple en tête les
jeux olympiques non c'est là mais on
sait jamais on ne l'avait jamais après
bon je pense que
je sais pas je sais papa maintenant je
pense pas pas de 1024 donc pas pour
l'instant je pense pas enfin peut-être
que je sais pas
bon en tout cas nous on vous remercie
d'avoir été là bon courage à vous mariam
bateau je le rappelle vous avez vous
êtes boxeuse et membre de la team
farrugia à elancourt merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous
edwards matt et a été mis en examen pour
viol atteintes sexuelles et harcèlement
le 14 janvier dernier le cas là le
cavalier de 40 ans aurait agressé quatre
femmes de 18 à 35 ans dont une mineure
au moment des faits et des plaintes ont
été déposées
une information révélée par le journal
du dimanche ce week end est directeur
technique de tendeurs capital stable
écurie de compétition et de commerce a
offert j dans les yvelines edwards matt
et a pour l'heure été interdits de
compétition par la fédération française
d'équitation
une information judiciaire a été ouverte
le 25 novembre dernier l enquête a été
confiée à la section de recherche des
yvelines par le paquet le parquet de
versailles
[Musique]
et le 17 janvier 2022 les résultats sont
tombés c'est le châtaignier et de la
celle saint cloud qui remporte le prix
du public de la 11e édition du concours
de l'arbre de l'année avec plus de
7750 vote est sélectionné en septembre
dernier parle pour le concours pardon de
terre sauvage et de l'eau nf il était en
compétition avec 12 autres arbres le
reportage dé sénéchal regarder il est
grand et majestueux et à ses propres
fans la star du jour c'est ce
châtaignier de la celle-saint-cloud cher
de ses 18 mètres d'envergure il pose
devant les appareils photos des
yvelinois venus en grand nombre pour le
voir la raison il vient de remporter le
titre de l'arbre de l'année je les ai
vus dans les magazines mais je me suis
dit je le prendre en photo ma mère se
châtaignier fait partie d'une plantation
qui a été fait sous louis xiv avait 350
châtaignier dans ce quartier c'est le
seul survivant il était exploité pour
deux choses d'une part pour les
châtaignes on faisait la farine de
châtaigne pour se nourrir et par
ailleurs comme il y avait des vignes sur
les coteaux de la région parisienne et
dans ce quartier en particulier on est
était régulièrement là pour faire les
échalas qui sont les piquer support des
7 de vignes à un arbre qui surprend les
curieux visiteurs par son physique il
fait quand même quatre mètres de large
il est énorme et il a une très grande
envergure et il est beau et je
reviendrai le voir avec des feuilles
excel est très très très vite
d'accord c'est très belle précède les
branches sont sont très harmonieuse et
puis le trou il est quand même spécial
il évrier et puis l'a350 en dhr ce
châtaignier âgée de trois cent trente
ans est situé dans un quartier
résidentiel au nom tout trouvé la
châtaigneraie y a pas que moi qui suis
fier l'ensemble de la ville est fière
les gens du quartier et tout
particulièrement puisque c'est le
symbole de leur association une
association de quartier très très
vivante qui connaît bien cet art qui le
surveillent attentivement en espérent
qu'ils ne tombe pas malade que 16 ans
ces branches seront pas cassé il a 330
en châtaignier ça peut vivre milan donc
sa prochaine étape c'est de doubler le
nombre
l'année qui la décharge et ce n'est pas
fini pour lui il représentera la france
au concours de l'arbre de l'année
européen en 2022
et côté transports sky bus poursuit sa
transition énergétique 41 nouveaux bus
donc alimentés au biométhane vont être
mis en circulation au centre
opérationnel bus de trappes la
conversion énergétique a débuté en 2021
et devrait s'achever en février à 2022
coût du projet 6 millions d'euros un
budget financé par ile-de-france
mobilité objectif à terme faire de l'île
de france la première région à atteindre
la décarbonisation de l'ensemble des
transports en commun en 2029 l'ensemble
des bus diesel du réseau francilien
devrait être remplacé près
2640 bus biométhane électriques sont
déjà en circulation dans la région
et au jardin naturel d'achever des
ateliers destinés aux débutants sont
proposées tous les samedis pour
apprendre à créer un beau jardin trois
heures pour apprendre à avoir la main
verte quand on vient d'acquérir par
exemple une propriété avec un espace de
jardinage les détails par mélanie poké
et bixente mais rien 110 tebbane pour
vous lécher en surface j'ai pas un
problème c'est pas prêt à ça c'est du
caca quoi parlent ils
sont souvent une dizaine petits et
grands pour venir parler biodiversité et
apprendre comment créer un beau jardin
l'idée c'est de pouvoir le mettre en
pratique pas uniquement faire les choses
sans
sans comprendre un petit peu comment ça
commence à fonctionner il va falloir
encore
là c'est sûr qu'à la fin de l'été s'est
fait d'accord on va pouvoir planter je
pense l'automne prochain un rendez-vous
pour combler un désir du retour à la
terre on a un petit peu
testé ça au premier confie mme braun un
peu par hasard et on a trouvé ça
intéressant de tester et puis de will de
mettre les mains dans la terre de
fabriquer soi même un petit bout de un
petit bout à manger les ateliers animés
par un jardiniers maraîchers de la
jardinerie de chevreuse tous les samedis
surtout destiné aux novices la plupart
du temps ce sont des débutants qui
viennent d'acquérir une maison ou qui
ont un jardin est d'accord il veut le
savoir comment entreprendre ce jardin
naturellement donc a sûrement mal
d'idées reçues la permaculture est très
à la mode et on lit pas toujours la
vérité quoi
quatre modules sont proposés pour
compléter son savoir faire et sa
parcelle de terre
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi dans un instant
retrouver michael et demi d'euros à la
présentation de votre magazine sportif
avec bixente mairie en santesteban pour
vos résultats du week-end très bonne
soirée à tous sur télé 78
[Musique]